and chef tom is here with thirteenth
world champion grandmaster garry
kasparov he's going to talk to us today
a little bit about master class Gary
you've had an Indian Twitter fan who
asked you how to get ready for a chess
tournament and you gave a very funny
response to stay off Twitter but this
kind of resembles master class where you
were talking to your members about
working hard so it wasn't really always
just a joke was it no it was a joke
yes if you want to prepare yourself for
the board match you have to concentrate
and I can tell you that staying with
Twitter doesn't help the concentration
because the contrary you know just it's
makes it feel easy and now I can afford
to stay Twitter you know on facebook on
other social media because I'm no longer
the professional chess player as you
could see he said lose but when I was
approached by master class to to do
these class series I have to confess
that I wasn't sure from the beginning
because yeah I watched of course Steve
Marty's in the villians I could see
other classes I could see the highest
quality of the production but how to
squeeze my knowledge of the game of
chess my experience my passion for the
game in six seven eight hours whatever
will be the final product and also what
is the what is the target audience
because there are so many people that
would like to hear what Garrick as far
as going to say about chess and this
this audience is crowd will be ranging I
knew ranging from total beginners to
very very decently strong players so
I've been contemplating so how could I
package my message how can I create
something that might be of interest for
as large audience as possible and so I
decided that it's not about being very
precise with some tactical tricks even
strategical concepts because there's so
many of them and it's it's just trying
to give the gist of what I think is
important for people to make progress
progress brendan from the level surgeon
to 1700 roughly that's understood would
be the potentially core audience but
most important the most important task
for me was to communicate my love and
passion for the game and also to
demonstrate the beauty of the game
because now we hear we hear time and
again out computer age chess chess is
being exhausted the game just lost its
its a magic touch it's no longer
exciting because you have computers
dominating the game big deal computers
are much faster than humans the course
for instance but people are still
running this did nobody is going to
cancel traffic through competitions but
those saying both is not competing yes
mercedes-benz and even the fact that
machines are now much stronger than
chess or in God or in any virtually any
other video or board game
it doesn't stop human competing -
against each other but most importantly
to enjoy the beauty of again sometimes
you can use machines to help you to
create very beautiful studies by the way
many of the of the best studies in the
decade they've been created with with
assistance of the computer and I think
that's it because I wanted to to choose
to to present this multi-dimensional
beauty of the game and of course you
know it's the final answer must come
from from the audience but I was happy
with the final product what feedback
have you gotten about your master class
class so far very positive people
recognized that it's impossible to teach
them to play high level chess in seven
hours or so but they they appreciate the
candid conversation it's about ending
the conversation that's the way I wanted
you to to build it is it's I talked to
someone so that's it's it's a
conversation and I'm trying to
communicate my
my passion for the game and even now 12
years after that professional chess I
haven't lost my my ability to be
mesmerized by some of the great
positions so I looking at some of the
studies and and and some of the games
played by my former colleagues just the
younger players now I I'm always looking
for something new and and since you know
I haven't lost my ability to be
surprised so he tells me that is to
plenty in the game of chess to be
discovered and any new step in revealing
the secrets of the game with new
machines new computers new chess engines
I mean I take I take as positive not
negative because it helps me to
understand this game deeper and people
understand the game so more we can enjoy
it I was there on set with you it was
three long days of filming of course
each day began with preparation and
everything was it comparable at all to a
chess game in any way in terms of your
fatigue or the way you prepared for it
oh it was challenging both physically
and psychologically I left the official
chest ages ago and I these days I'm not
used to you know such an intense program
it's many hours many many hours a day so
typical typically my activities now
involve speeches 45 minutes 60 minutes
maybe it goes to 90 minutes of Q&A then
maybe book signing simple medicine
organized exhibition but this those are
not the same activities that that demand
you know you're the food physical and
mental concentration for many hours so
that's why they were one of the problems
I expressed in in st. Louis that since
it's very difficult to to change the
algorithm that's that is working inside
of your brains to help you to to to
mmediately the challenges you do English
but
what help me at this I do to myself
because I had to go through so many
files and so many options how to present
this idea that idea just look at my own
games and games a lot of players and I
ended up with something quite
comprehensive so it's a it's it's it's
normal that that when you are facing
such a big challenge and you end up with
something that is so slow it's it's
satisfactory and you're happy with that
that that re-energized your motherís
tethers I saw you tweeted recently about
Steph Curry's masterclass I'm wondering
if you've watched any of the other
master classes Gordon Ramsay or any
leave of any of those actually yes can
too many but this is this is the tuna I
enjoyed it was I tried to look at the
professional presentation was Steve
Martin and some of the volumes I mean
not that I was planning to you become
comedian or tennis player but again
willing to understand you know what is
what is the what is the best way to to
to set up this intimate atmosphere with
your students because you talking to
thousands if not millions but at the end
of the day it's you and one person so
it's very important that this person
doesn't feel that he or she is a part of
a crowd but it's it's something that
each of them could enjoy and also learn
individually you have incredible drive
and passion I'm curious if you ever come
across another professional athlete who
you think shares the kind of drive and
passion you had during your playing days
look I think everybody who once went to
the very top could make it without
without a passion so that's why I
wouldn't make
that we mentioned just names because
look at anybody who makes top five and
thought of them she took one
it was our passion was a full dedication
without concentration and sacrifice you
will they'll make it you filmed your
master class in the spring of 2017 and
then you came back to rated chess in the
summer of 2017
I'm just curious was there any part of
filming the master class that built up a
little bit of extra inspiration to
finally say yes you're gonna come back
to competitive chess yes it's it's not
just a masterclass itself but also the
you make all the environment said news
it's a place where you know I feel that
you know playing chess is fun and while
I was quite skeptical about my chances
of playing well so but it was hard to
you to to resist these distant ation and
when after a few you know rejections of
other playoff potential wildcards to to
join the Grand Prix and and an open an
invitation for Wrexham Phil how could I
say no
it says I knew it would you know it
would require total change of my routine
and I could make it because I still had
to fly back and forth I had so many
already prior arrangements like he just
speaking of death called in Las Vegas
and I had to go back to my family in
Europe so it was not a preparation that
garry kasparov 20 years ago would up
with the proof so without proof because
it's in order to to compete seriously
against top wall players I mean I needed
probably two months of full
concentration maybe stayin in solutions
only or didn't even stay in Croatia but
but just doing nothing else but playing
chess thinking about chess and washing
out everything else was not possible so
I had probably taught on a couple of
weeks of preparation just playing a few
training matches but and I you know I
had some ideas and I anytime I think I
go back to San Luis just in summer 2017
think about some of these games it's
it's almost a nightmare because I got
many good positions and and those
several games where I play part of the
game I play like Garry Kasparov bits I
don't want to think what's happened the
rest of it again and every realistically
speaking with some good preparation and
wheezed in their ways being my state of
mind being just you know focused on the
game I would definitely make top 5 by
the way I was the only one in this
horror just it's horrible torment for me
I was staring at one point away from
just coming big top 5 I think it's just
maybe I could make tops recess so that's
that's the realistic so having plus one
plus two in rapid and plus three in
Boyds it's not it's not beyond my
ability to achieve but you know they
it's it was not about scoring these
points it was about having fun for
myself but also sharing this farm was
the rest of the crowd was people so this
I thought it was a very good way of
showing my appreciation to racing sinful
and sin whose organizers because they
had so much publicity and I was in the
center of that no matter you know what
was the result
I still had you know I could enjoy it
and you know I showed that I still could
invent few ideas you know like pushing
h4 and and it's the most inappropriate
woman supporting to you to do a
conventional wisdom so its overall was a
good experience and you cannot separate
my basins and Lewis recording
masterclass with this decisions because
again said Lewis always create special
chess atmosphere and and temptation to
go back to the chessboard whether for
teaching or even for playing yeah for
many generations it was the first time
seeing play competitive chess so it was
a treat I know during the master class
you asked your students to be very
self-critical and analyze their games
have you gone back in intense and looked
at those games I know they were just
rapid and blitz but have you really done
a deep dive into those games that you
played deep dive I just looked at some
of them now as computer it easy button
so most of the games are the same
pattern I play very good game and
excellent positions of those winning
positions sometimes in case of navarre
it's absolutely position and then there
was a blackout Salem
there was not much I'd learn from the
chest angle it was more about psychology
and I mean I knew that it's it's
something that I had to accept as the as
a very sad reality that is I'm no longer
able just to play even even rapid games
was the same level of concentration and
dedication as before so again there was
plenty of potential we thought that I
was you know lost from the beginning it
was not that you know I showed no no
sign of hope way but maybe somehow it
was you know it was a conspiracy of the
game of chess against me because it
would be probably wrong for me go back
after 12 years of of inactivity and also
not concentrating on the to on that's
that's somehow it's punishment because
you know you want to play well you have
to spend your time you have to make it a
priority and no circumstance I could
make the priority because I had other
things family obligations to go back to
Europe and back and forth and also by
appearances professional in tourism
because now I'm not a chess player
professional just well you know I'm part
of speaking to soaked and certain things
that have been arranged to advance I
could install so I think it was you know
there was some justice there like a
message from provocation so you don't
want to concentrate fine well you know
will will will teach Ulis you imagine
your desire to finish the top three or
top five is just what were the way if
the door open a little bit even a little
bit for you to try this again I don't
know right now I don't think about it I
doubt it will be next year so just
because if you dude you know this is I
cannot afford to do it again the same
way that I did in 2017 then you need
just to make sure if you have enough
time to prepare just to having to
because if you do it again it should be
a test so what what what everybody can
do if I spend you know certain amount of
time to concentrate and to prepare
myself for for this challenge facing top
players I'm not sure I have this time
available so I wouldn't say no no no
but it's it's it's unlikely and Jeff has
been in the mainstream there's a lot
this last month the first was the alphas
euronews what did you make of this
program or do you found about alpha zero
but I think it's it's it's a good useful
chest because we could learn a lot from
from the way alpha zero plays because
what I understand now is the states he
established its own skill of evaluation
so set of priorities which is quite a
unique accomplishment because typically
every problem has this set of priorities
and it's it's not flexible so they they
make many slight alterations but in
general they have to stick with the
original numbers that are attached to
each each priority in this evaluation
mechanism now alpha 0 after playing
millions and millions of games came up
with own set of values we need more
games that ten games with as we could
see that's not enough but the fact that
crushed sawfish and stop fishes is
deadly for any any human plan so it's
probably sue these three to four hundred
play strengths today again I don't know
what is stated they had the strongest
hardware for stock fish I'm sure there's
two plenty of improvement there I'm sure
the humans can after learning how alpha
chess play they can make some extra
improvements for or for for stock fish
but still you know the result was
amazing
now what was most amazing is that when I
looked at it just statistically it's the
white and black so alpha chess was told
the deadly he was white while I was
black it was it was winning but but very
small margin now doesn't tell us that we
totally I misunderstand the value of the
first move because in in human chess and
also in in the games played by other
computers like stop fish in Canada the
percentage of games won by white isn't I
mean it's it's 53 54 55 percent but they
seventy-five percent this is not this is
not one we saw in that match so I think
we can learn a lot and I looking just to
to to study these war games and I keep
talking demis hassabis I have to say
that it's just a very brief encounter
with his team in London very impressive
very impressive this is you know it's
probably more revolution that people
think because this is the inherence
since I've been doing several lectures
on AI and and and human and machine
collaborations and the future of humans
and machines I have to say that alpha
chess
accomplishment alpha zero accomplishment
because if those go on chess it's just
it's the same concept of starting on the
scratch just having the rules I mean
that could have dramatic impact on on
the way will conduct many operations
intellectual operations but overall I
think it's positive and I would I would
be panicking because that access to
these machines gives us unique
opportunity to learn more about the
games even if we thought that we had you
know we're precise knowledge because it
always demonstrates the imperfection of
all knowledge and and that's for me
that's that's the that's the best news
because I'm older willing to learn and
suddenly I discovered wow maybe certain
things I didn't understand about the
game or just maybe whitey now could have
bigger advantage and maybe certain
openings simply don't work because look
at these games it's so so entertaining
and then and again I'm looking forward
for more in there more information about
alpha chess and more matches with alpha
chairs and of traditional type a chess
problems that had that based on the
brute force algorithms yeah they're
certainly beauty and perfection of will
close with the other way that Chester
than remain stirring news some would say
has to do with beauty and that's the new
logo for the World Championship have you
seen it and what are your thoughts on it
it's the most amazing thing about this
model is that according to you a good
less than one year working on it okay I
wonder how much mine was paid for this
longer because I think the the the
greatest beauty of the logger for those
who created it is the amount of money
that has been spent on this world for a
year I'm very skeptical about any
contribution to the game of chess made
by a gun and alike because for me it's
just it's it's still part of the old
feed operation to money laundering
operation and if sometimes they come up
with something that looks attractive
okay
justice everybody can have a good day or
bad day but I'm no hope at all that
alien or another Hagen any company that
is just you know is connected to the old
corrupt field machinery will do the good
job promoting the game so it's a it's
it's it's a cheap shot it just brings
attention but then it just you know it's
it comes and goes
now we need you know we need strategy
how to develop a new commercial
advertising console for the game of
chess by the way also including
computers and other things that are
happening and it seems to me that now
feed is preoccupied with with this
in-house fighting they keep fighting
needs each other and and I think that as
long as the World Championship match
remains in the hands of one faction of
feed or another it will be more for the
same Protestant purposes as as it has
been for last decades or simply for
laundering the money as we proceed
occasionally well fantastic thanks for
your time I know you had a lot of chess
positions that did not make it in the
master class we're about to see a few of
your favorites but thanks again garry
kasparov